i did hear a dog bark while you were  speaking so eloquently in the background  yeah yeah that was bo yeah  okay well i he doesn't know that i'm on  a podcast you didn't explain you  didn't explain to beau that i did no i  did in fact  i had someone give him meat to take him  away  then he's like right up under my feet  breathing he breathes heavy he's just  such a heavy breather and then it's all  these plugs i'm like you're gonna unplug  everything you know  i wish you would i'm guessing that you  probably put someone in charge of  keeping  uh an eye on beaujolais i thought i did  you know what i say to that  thanks obama  i know just who to blame i know just  who to blame